trying to fit that in yeah it's hard you
cannot especially in boxing the sweet
science where it's just hands but you
got people that's all he do all day long
right that's why I say it's so unfair
when an MMA guy goes into fights at
Mayweather because Mayweather he
perfected that yeah and you got to use
just that style of boxing it's gonna be
almost impossible to be the box or a
roll champion boxer did you watch the
New Year's fight that thing that he did
with the attention yeah yeah yeah a lot
of people think that was a fixed fight I
think that was a 120 pound fighter
fighting the best ever yeah I mean it's
just this it wasn't a fixed fight I
don't know why people think it's a fixed
fight that guy fights it 126 pounds I
think yeah I think that's his weight
class and you could definitely tell the
size anyways just like I could actually
tell the size difference though when
McGregor fought yeah you know I think
both the Floyd's legs equal to one of
McGregor's yeah but yeah with that
tension that fight the first knockdown
was legit yeah and I think my personal
opinion what happened it wasn't fixed
you know were fake I believe that he got
hit with that right hand and it seemed
that how strong and how to defense the
skills that uh Mayweather had and I
think he said you know what this could
be a long-ass night and then the next
couple punches he just kind of like went
down because he seen what could happen
he knew which way that fight was going
really yeah that's what you think I do
it the first knockdown let's go so let's
play that fight see if you can find the
fight and play it I feel like the first
one clipped him on the temple he hit
with a left hook on the temple he didn't
with a right hand but didn't hit him
with a left hook the right hand and then
he hit him afterwards as well as he's
going down but I think that left hand to
the temple is what did the real damage
and then then there was a big right hand
afterwards it dropped him I just think
he was out of his League he's away way
out of his League not that he took a
dive but almost to the point of like he
knew that that fight was not going
anyway - wait he thought it was he looks
he was so smiley and relaxed it was kind
of funny you know we just sort of walked
the dude down he had a big ol smile and
say look at him smiling was last night
and he's so much like my kid right yeah
he's fighting like it's a joke like look
at him he's so much bigger than this kid
what's really funny is if they let
kid kick he would [ __ ] Floyd up yeah
okay Floyd may look so dumb and I didn't
even know on that part but then again
that kid his kicks that kid would have
kicked Floyd's legs out from under him
in seconds Oh what you went too far
there see he got up right there boom see
he hit him with the left hook and he
stumbled and then he hit him with the
right hand behind it and I just think
he's too little
he's just a he's a very small guy and
for him I mean and Floyd's not a big guy
this kid is tiny I mean I think he's
fought as light as 121 pounds and I
think sometimes he fights it like 126
yeah maybe I think you can see right
there right there sometimes at a fight a
lot of times in a fight the whole issue
is you get hit with that and you're
fighting if somebody taps you with a
certain punch your brain you'll be
surprised how fast it works you know and
all the things that go through that mind
boom yes that's that was it yep and I
think at that moment right there he just
knew going in you could fill just was
somebody hit you on the arm or a
shoulder you know how much power they
have and I think he's just trying to
after that he knew that was gonna be a
long night so crazy they paid him 9
million dollars for this must be nice
[Laughter]
yeah I mean [ __ ] there was a lot of
people I seen going up he deserves to
give some of these prospects a chance
now you know he should be fighting these
guys instead of doing this these guys
ain't boxers blah blah blah and my take
on that also is the man went 40 49 50
you know he fought almost everybody in
the sport even if you wanted to say that
they were past her prime some of them
made that a little bit he still went in
there and dominated them and beat them
yes this guy in my opinion if he wanted
to fight defensive backs from the NFL he
has all the right in a role I don't
think that he owes the sport anything I
think actually it's the other way around
the amount of money that he has brought
to the sport the attention that he
brought to it so if he wants to go
around in duty size shows let him you
know I mean what do you want to do fight
prospects til he's 51 years old I
couldn't agree more I couldn't agree
more
it's crazy the idea that they want to
see him sacrificed yeah they want to see
him get beat that's how they want
see him finally fight someone who's
younger and faster and hungrier who's
more active and what will happen is that
he will lose and I think maybe was a
smarter net you know he wants to go out
and keep that his status and and and
that the record that he built up and
that resume that he has and go out like
that yeah well they're talking about him
fighting khabib nurmagomedov who's the
UFC 155 pounds anton but could be he was
not really a boxer he's I just want to
say but boxing rules yeah oh that would
be a same thing yeah Kabhi was a
takedown ground-type yeah exactly it
would be the same kind of fight as the
counter fight the only difference is I
don't think could be but get as tired as
Conor would I know I don't think he's
definitely got better endurance I think
one of the only few in there right now
that would be a good fight would be one
of the Diaz brothers as far as striking
that would be interesting but they did
he would box their face off but he said
I still think that he would win that but
I'm just saying as far as you know
stand-up and letting the hands go I
think Jose were wanted to one of the two
better ones in the MMA yeah I mean he's
got all the right in the world to just
keep fighting freakshows doesn't have
fun man and you know wait with her the
only thing is you know father time shows
up you know he's getting to that age
where you might get one of them guys and
yeah so I mean every type of fun do it
but if you go and get beat by one of
them guys I could change the whole
outlook of a career
well it's interesting how guys who are
really good defensively they're not just
really good longer because they have
such good technique but also they've
taken less damage during their career so
that they're more durable as they get
older as well like you've definitely saw
that with Bernard like Bernard up until
the Joe Smith fight me Joe Smith was the
first guy to really put it on him like
that and knock him out of the ring and
it was hard to see it was hard to see
that they they had that ring set up to
where he fell and landed on his [ __ ]
head Jesus Christ you know I don't know
if those so much to ring I just think it
was an awkward way that he went out of
them ropes yeah in a way because he got
hurt by that punch yeah so and the legs
buckled and when you the legs buckle
like that dink I put him in that awkward
position for him to slide out you know
his ass was headed out and you know get
clipped again went right through but I
mean it just sucks that there's nothing
to
protect the fighters if they fall out
like that there's no padding there's no
no tables no enough to nothing to break
your fall no one therefore you just got
to hope one of the ringside judges or
commentators or their - that's crazy and
you got guys that are 80 years old
yeah try to push a 200-pound man back in
the ring yeah they're not gonna get
clipped like that and one to somebody
falling on them but Bernard was able to
keep his skill very late in life I mean
deep into his 40s almost a 50 years old
was still world-class which is really
crazy that is then you got a handful of
guys out there that could do that and to
be honest you know but he kept himself
in good shape in between fights yeah and
he did what he was supposed to do and
some guys you know you get some guys out
there good friend of mine my trainer
Robert Garcia retired at 29
a young style guy Mancini retired young
and came back a couple years later but
it was only for one fight because who
did Mancini come back against Greg
Halligan oh that's right yeah yep and
some of them you know some guys they go
in and do it and it's fun and then it
becomes a career a job and financial
security you know the way a lot of
fighters look at it and then you get
some guys like Floyd Manny Pacquiao
Bernard Hopkins who just loved the sport
you know that much that does they don't
know anything else outside of it so